all right here we go
so what you said when you sat down was
absolutely perfect that the timing could
not have been better well tell everybody
what you do Michael well thank you I'm a
four AB lack of a better term of medical
detective I've spent my whole career
tracking infectious diseases down trying
to stop him try to understand where they
come from so we can make sure they don't
happen in the first place but most of
all trying to respond to situations just
like this just like this and just out
off the bat how serious is this is this
something that we need to be terrified
of or is this overblown or how do you
stand on this well first of all you have
to understand the timing of it in the
sense that is just beginning and so in
terms of what hurt pain suffering death
this account happened so far is really
just beginning this is going to unfold
for months to come yet and that's I
think what people don't quite yet
understand what we saw in China I'm
convinced as are many of my colleagues
as soon as they release all of these
social distances these mandated stay in
homes haven't left your home in weeks
and weeks kind of thing when they go
back to work they're on planes trains
subways buses crowded spaces
manufacturing plants even China is going
to come back again and so this really is
acting like an influenza virus something
that transmits very very easily through
the air we now have data to show that
your infectious before you even get sick
and in some cases quite highly
infectious just breathing is all that
you need to do so from this perspective
I can understand why people would say
well wait a minute flu kills a lot more
itself every year than this does and
already remind people this just was
beginning probably the best guesstimate
we have right now on what limited data
we have is say this could be at least 10
to 15 times worse than the worst
seasonal flu year we see 10 to 15 times
worse in terms of fatalities yeah yeah
and just illness in fact I just brought
some numbers we can serve ly estimate
that this could require 48 million
hospitalizations 96 million cases
actually occurring over 480 thousand
deaths that can occur over the next
three to seven months with this
situation so this is not one that to
take lightly and I think that's what I
can understand if you say was over 10
or twenty dos or 50 deaths just remember
two weeks ago we are talking about
almost no cases in the United States and
now that we're testing for it and
watching the spread as its unfolding
those numbers going up astronomically
three weeks ago Italy was just living
life just fine now they're literally in
a virtual shutdown in the northern parts
of Italy and that's the challenge with
an infectious disease like this it can
spread very quickly and it also can
affect people I think maybe to put this
into modern terms this is something we
think of often and we think of you know
pre-antibiotic days you know the
old-time medicine we have an employee at
our Center for infectious research and
policy at the University of Minnesota
and she has a dear friend who lives in
Milan Italy and she works at a hospital
there and she texted us to this employee
of ours last night and this was an email
that came out yesterday from one of
their physicians in Milan at the largest
hospital there he said I just got a very
disturbing message from a cardiologist
at one of the Milan's largest hospitals
they're deciding who they have to let
die they aren't screening the staff
anymore because they need all hands on
deck and they have very small areas of
the hospital dedicated to non kovat
patients where they still screen doctors
everybody else is dedicated to kovat
patients so even if they're positive
meaning that they're sick they don't and
but they don't have a severe cough or
fever then they have to work he says
that that they're seen an alarming
number of cases in the forty-something
range rage and as he took horrible cases
so we need to stop thinking that this
isn't only an old person's disease that
this is what's I'm gonna unfold not just
in wuhan its unfolding in Milan its
unfolding here in Seattle and this is
what's going to continue to rolling Lee
unfold throughout the world yeah where
did this rumor come from that it's a an
old person's disease is it just because
the majority of the people that have
died from it so far I've been older yes
in fact that's the primary risk factor
for Diana's being old and then having
certain underlying health problems for
example in China those men over the age
of 70 who also smoked were eight to ten
percent of them died sixty-five percent
of older Chinese men smoked the
case fatality rate or the percentage of
people who die and women in that same
age group is only about two percent in
that case what very few women smoked now
the challenge we have is that's the
Chinese data but there are a series of
risk factors that we worry about that if
they overlay on this disease are going
to cause bad outcomes and we happen to
be right at Ground Zero for one of the
major ones here in this country that's
obesity we know that obesity is just
like smoking in terms of its ability to
really cause severe life-threatening
disease and forty-five percent of our
population today over the age of 45 in
this country are obese or sevillio obese
and there's men and women so one of the
concerns we have is we're gonna see more
of these what I would guess I would call
very serious and life-threatening cases
occur in our country because of a
different set of risk factors and we saw
in China now you mentioned that there's
some sort of incubation period before
people become sick they're still
contagious what is this incubation
period and how do we know about it when
we call something an incubation paper
talking about from the time you and I
got exposed meaning I was in a room
breathe in the air that somebody else
who was infected with the virus was
expelling out I breathed it in how long
from that time period till the time
period that you get sick and what is
that it's that's what called incubation
period so that's when case numbers can
double or triple in every so many days
in this case is about four days so and
we actually have data there from people
who are exposed one time or one time
only and we know when they were exposed
where they were exposed and how soon do
they get sick afterwards so the
chauffeur in the car where that an
individual is sick or showing symptoms
then the show forgets that four days
later you know they were there one time
at one time long and if the chauffeur
does not show any symptoms he's still
contagious he can also be contagious too
or he and that's one of the things
that's challenging here is you and I
might get exposed to somebody who is
totally asymptomatic no symptoms that
virus that appear well that's not a very
strong virus but in fact when it infects
us it could kill us so we've seen cases
of fatal disease that were exposed to
people that had minor symptoms
themselves Wow
this is what's unfolding here and this
is where I think is such an important
you know I said why the timing is
important because you know Joe we really
got to get information out to the public
there is so much missing from
information right now and you know we're
gonna be this for a while this is not
gonna happen overnight I worry I keep
telling people we're handling this like
it's a corona blizzard you know two or
three days more Mattoon normal this is a
coronavirus winter and we're gonna have
the next three months or more six months
or more that are going to be like this
and you know so far this thing has been
unfolding exactly as we predicted it we
and our center put out a piece on
January 20th and said this is going to
spread worldwide have time people said I
had no it's just China we put out a
piece the first week of February and
said this is gonna pop probably the last
week of February first week of March
because what happens is it has what's
called an R nought or a doubling time of
these every four days so to to increase
is doubling every four days so if you go
from two to four to eight to sixteen it
takes a while to build up but when you
start going from five hundred to a
thousand to two thousand to four
thousand that's what we're seeing happen
in places like Italy we're beginning to
see it in some ways up in Seattle it's
what happened in China and you know when
people are confronted with that suddenly
this low risk phenomena that ever talks
about isn't so low anymore and that's we
need to prepare people for now what can
be done like what what can the average
person do I see people walking around
with masks on wearing gloves is that
nonsense
largely yes first of all let's step back
the primary mechanism for transmission
is just the respirator out it's just
breathing in studies in Germany which
just have been published literally in
the last 24 hours
they actually followed a group of people
who had been exposed to somebody at
automobile manufacturing plant and then
they had nine people that with this
exposure he said if you have any
symptoms at all contact us we want to
follow up with and they all agreed
well they got infected and so in the
very first hours just feeling bad sore
throat they went in and sampled the
throats their their saliva their nose
for virus they did blood they did stool
they did urine and they found that at
that very moment when they first got
sick they had incredibly high levels of
virus sometimes ten thousand times that
we saw with SARS in their throats
meaning they were infectious at that
point already they hadn't even had
symptoms yet of really any nature they
were coughing yet
and and that's where we're concerned
because that's the kind of transmission
it's you know I always have said trying
to stop influence Irish transmission
like try to stop the wind you know we've
never had anything successfully do that
other than vaccine and we don't have a
vaccine here so what's happening is that
people in public spaces are getting
infected and the way you need to address
that is unfortunately if you're older
over 55 you have some underlying health
problems which unfortunately a lot of
Americans do we have obesity then right
now you don't want to be in large public
spaces in trying to potentially get
infected so you can take care of that
part as far as what can public health do
we reckon we can talk about this we're
not gonna have a vaccine anytime soon
that's happy talk well we you know we
can close schools one of the big
challenges we have right now if we close
schools what do we accomplish in
influenza virus when you we close
schools and during outbreaks because it
turns out kids are get infected in
school and they're like little virus
reactors you know they come home and
they transmit it to mom and dad and
brothers and sisters and so we closed
school sometimes it's Christmas breaks
are always great for kind of putting the
dampening effect on flu in this case
kids are not getting sick very often at
all which is one of the really good news
features of this disease into China only
2.1 percent of the cases are under 8 19
years of age why is that you know we
don't completely know and and I'm going
to come back in a second because they're
getting infected it turns out one study
showed that they still get infected with
the virus but they don't get sick and we
have that happen there's a disease
called infectious hepatitis hepatitis A
where we have outbreaks and daycares and
the way we know I have an outbreak is
because it's transmitted through the
stool fecal-oral is mom and dad and the
daycare providers all get sick and the
kids don't symptoms we go in and test
the kids they're all positive so some
diseases will manifest my primary when
you're adult but not as a child this one
appears to be the same so do we close
schools or not if we're not really
spreading the disease because it turns
out that if we close schools we own a
recent study done showed that 38% of
nurses today in this country who are
working in the medical carrier have kids
to school and if suddenly we're closing
schools for two or three months who's
gonna take care of those kids one-fourth
of the American population has no
sick leave if we closed goals they don't
get paid if they have to stay home so
when you ask what can we do we have to
really be thoughtful about what we do
are we doing more harm than good by
closing schools for example even though
everybody will say oh we got to do
everything we can or do we just tell
people you know it's going to be
limiting your contact as much as you can
and that's really about what we can do
and limiting the contact is that really
gonna help it does because it's like
putting rods in a reaction if you if you
don't have as much close contact you can
you know not transmit as much if I'm if
I'm sitting in a room with a hundred
people and we're kind of sharing air the
transmission is remarkable right here
you off the coast of California you've
got your cruise ship cruise ships are
notorious for recirculating air inside
the inner cabins we've had a number of
outbreaks that's why they're having
these outbreaks on cruise ships and then
you leave them on there I think the
cruelest human experiment we've done in
a long time yeah just leave them on
these ships get them off right away
should they get them all absolutely
whatever I do with them well they can
put them in quarantine of some kind of
if they want and follow up on them but
you're guaranteed they're all going to
keep getting infected day after day it
seems like we're not really prepared for
something like this although the the
CDC's been telling us for a long time
that we should be you know we are not
prepared at all in the sense you know I
wrote the book deadliest enemies that
was published in 2017 thank you thank
you go get it no an Manik in a chapter
13 the title of the chapter was SARS and
MERS a harbinger of things to come
you know predicted this and then I wrote
a chapter on there what a flu pandemic
would look like if it emerged in China
and if you read it it's exactly what's
happened the supply chains went down
China locked down the country it spread
to other countries people all pointed
fingers and you know it's it's the kind
of thing where we hear it and here at
Bou don't get prepared you know five
years ago I gave a talk at the Mayo
Clinic first time I talked about this
I've talked many times afterwards and I
showed a slide of Puerto Rico picture
was for a recall and then I showed the
map and then I showed a picture of a
building in Puerto Rico a nondescript
building and I said this is our next big
disaster turns out that 85% of all the
world's production of IV bags the Saline
that we need desperately were made in
these plants in Puerto Rico and all we
needed was one
category five hurricane to come through
and take it out Maria came through a
year and a half ago and the world went
into a major crisis with shortage of IV
bags now that was so obvious that was
going to happen and yet we don't prepare
that's so foolish I know I agree and
that's what hopefully this is a wake-up
call the business community I hopefully
will wake up you know one of the other
things we're doing right now
Joe this is really one of the things
that has been most concerned about this
whole situation is our group has been
studying for the last year and a half
with support from the Walton family
foundation looking at critical drug
shortages it turns out that we
identified a hundred and fifty three
drugs in this country that people need
right now or they die I mean it's on the
crash card it's acute critical drugs
one-hundred percent or more generic all
of them basically are made offshore of
the United States and large part them
were made in China and India and at this
point we have shortages anyway every day
just before this crisis happened now
these supply chains have gone down our
group is actively helping the United
States government try to figure out you
know where they can get these drugs now
just think of this if I came to you and
said the Defense Department was going to
outsource all this to munitions
production to China you'd look at me and
say come on you know what the US Defense
Department has no more access to these
drugs and anybody else they are beholden
to China for these drugs six hundred
ninety thousand Americans have un stage
renal disease right now most of their
primary drugs are coming from China and
now with the shutdown and what's
happening with this and this is what I
talked about in the book why I was so
concerned because we are at risk so even
the situation is unfold it's not just
about what the virus does to you it's
about what the entire system is rigged
up to be and what this virus does once
it gets into it Jesus you making me
nervous well but that's before we get
done here we're gonna talk about what we
can do to get people not nervous
because this it's too late no no no what
I mean is we're gonna we're gonna bring
you around to take you know it's my job
is not scary out of your wits scare you
and your wits do we do about it
sorry let me ask you something about
sauna use one of the things that I read
was that if you are in contact that 20
minutes in a sauna in a really hot sauna
is very good for killing some of the
virus is that yes Jesus Christ
these people yeah there was a some Sun a
fax thing that was being pushed around
that it's great for flu and all sorts of
infectious diseases actually it's great
for it I mean it makes you feel good but
we don't have any evidence that makes
any difference an infectious disease why
is so it doesn't have any impact at all
the idea was that the breathing in of
the very hot air 180 degree air for 20
minutes to kill some of the virus see if
that temperature of 180 degree air got
really into your lungs your lungs would
be fry it you'd be dead well how so so
so what happens is just from the time
you breathe it in and what you mix it
with the air there it's kind of like
taking a cup of hot water and putting it
into a bathtub of cold water and so what
happens by the time you get done it's
not that hot and so in this case your
lungs couldn't stand even hundred and
ten to 20 degree heat without causing
real severe damage and so it doesn't
kill the virus at all so it would the
virus and I would be like just in your
mouth or something like that even then
no no that's unfortunate because that
was those exciting I was reading that I
was like don't stop using the sonic it's
a good thing don't use for your skin and
everything else but yeah but it's not
going to help you with this one so how
does it cool the air down what's
happening in terms of your lungs right
yeah what you basically is some mixture
of you know when you breathe out you
don't breathe all the air out okay I
mean you that would you'd almost be dead
you couldn't do the tidal volume so what
happens is every breath well in other
words you have so much air in your lungs
already when you breathe out you breathe
just a little bit of it out and each
time you could bring more in out in and
out and so when this mixes in the hot
air like that or the very cold air you
know in Minnesota when you're 45 below
zero we have the same problem we don't
freeze our lungs okay you know when we
breathe then may feel cool and so it's
just there's so much in there that it
mixes with the other air and it
ultimately doesn't the temperature your
lungs don't change even if you're doing
like some crazy deep breathing exercises
where you slowly exhale all the air out
there's nothing left and then breathe it
all the way in I'm giving you my best
shot at it it's not gonna make much
difference sorry
I've always wanted
about like people that are in like
Alberta and it's like 50 degrees below
zero like how do they do that
yeah well we do it all the time as well
we don't anymore in Minnesota it's
getting warmer there every winter but
the problem right yeah we we surely know
what cold airs like well so much for
that myth myth number two well I don't
say myth I should say rumor was that
this was something from some sort of a
biological weapons thing that was linked
right because wuhan is some area what
part of China that they actually do work
on biological weapons and we've heard
that loud and clear and let me just give
a little bit background aboard in my
career back in the early 1990s I got
very involved and the whole area of bio
defense and bioterrorism
bio warfare it turned out I was involved
with helping to an interview and get
information from some of the Russian bio
weapon errors after the Wall fell and
Russia collapsed we had all these
experts coming out who had been spending
their whole lives making bio weapons and
it became very clear to me this was
really a serious challenge and as part
of my work I I spent a lot of time in
this area and I actually through a
series of serendipitous events became a
personal adviser His Majesty King
Hussein of Jordan before he died on this
topic I got really into it I wrote a
book that was published on 9/11 of 2000
called living terrors what our country
needs totals five becoming bioterrorist
catastrophe and I think I bought eight
of the twelve copies that were sold in
that year afterwards and then when 9/11
happened of course then it became really
prominent and then I went on to serve on
a group here in the United States that
was basically the National Science
Advisory Board of biosecurity safety
issues so I've had a lot of experience
in this area and so I bring that to the
table and I tell you there is no
evidence whatsoever that this is a
bioweapon or that it was accidentally
released from the Wuhan lab today with
the genetics we have on these viruses
and how we can do testing we can almost
date them almost like carbon testing you
know so radiocarbon you want to know how
old my block is or something like that
this thing clearly jumped from an animal
species probably the third week in
November to humans and penguins you know
the scaly anteater
animals are very good source because we
have coronaviruses just like those in
these animals and it got into a human so
you know we've surely had a lot of
challenges with that but I don't believe
that there's any evidence linking those
two I want an intentional release or an
accidental release or that it's an
engineered bug is not my friend Duncan
and I did a show back in 2012 ish
somewhere around there with sci-fi where
we went to the CDC in Galveston and we
talked to them about that very thing and
they said the real concern the real
concern is just actual diseases it's not
man-made diseases disease that's exactly
I mean look you know we could not have
crafted a virus like this to do what
it's doing I mean we don't have the
creative imagination or the skill set if
somebody said okay I want to find a
virus it'll take out a lot of people
okay this what mother nature does it so
much better than we could ever do it and
you know whether it was Ebola whether
it's this one or its antibiotic
resistance any of these things I mean
you know and regular and I were talking
about the potential for chronic wasting
disease to be a problem for humans you
know mother nature's doing it pretty
well in her own the chronic wasting one
really scares me because there's so many
people that have a vested interest in
dismissing it I had our good friend Doug
durin yep on the podcast with I don't
remember the gentleman that he brought
with it right Richard thank you Ryan
Richards who explain the science behind
it and there are so many people that are
dismissing this because either they
enjoyed deer hunting or they they want
captive servants to be something that
are still something that you could be
released on private property
most people grow and breed deer and then
sell them to ranchers who want deer and
their properties particularly large deer
and I mean guys that I have talked to
that are dismissing it I can see the
chain of events that they want it to be
not a concern but if you see what it's
doing to deer it's terrifying it's a
hundred percent fatal it the the DNA
exists on plants for years they leak it
out of their saliva they leave traces of
it everywhere and in Doug's area there's
some some near is somewhere near there
there's like 50% infection range right
I listen I think this is really a
significant challenge I was involved
back in the 1990s and into the 1980s
when Mad Cow first emerged in England
and at the time was asked to give an
assessment when this was all this bovine
spongiform encephalopathy another prion
so these prion sir what causes disease
and you know people want to dismiss it
that people weren't gonna get sick well
then we realize ten years later all
these human cases started to show up
that from those exposures ten years
before and it took a while before those
prions obviously changed in the cattle
to get to the point where they didn't
affect humans well the same thing is
happening with a deer if you look back
on the deer population that were
infected 30 years ago and you look at it
today the prions are constantly changing
they're mutating and they're they're new
strains and they're getting more
human-like all the time and one of the
things our Center is doing is we're
looking at working on that very issue of
trying to help people understand that
the studies that were done 15 or 20
years ago looking at how infectious
these might be for humans we're really
well done they were good but they had
different strains and over time these
strains are looking to be more more like
they could infect humans or they could
even infect cattle which would be
another huge challenge if that happened
and so I think your points a really good
one and we know today that they're
probably at least 17,000 deer that were
consumed in the past year that were
actually positive for this prion and
people went ahead native anyway so I
worry about that too that's terrifying
so these people have these prions in
their system now but then currently
they're not they're not making the jump
to cause what is it yacouba's
creutzfeldt-jakob disease which is what
yeah it's kind of a we don't know that
humans are getting infected one of the
challenges we don't have a test unless
you die and then that's the heck of a
way to have to get a test or something
okay so one of the challenges you don't
know this until you actually show up
with the signs and symptoms and so one
of the things that we're looking at
carefully is doing surveillance or
disease detection among people that
might present with this if it's going to
happen
I suspect the naturally occurring prion
related diseases lights
creutzfeldt-jakob disease you just
mentioned occurs typically in older
people over 70
if you sudden start seeing the 40 year
old or a 50 year old or 60
even with this disease then you got to
start thinking what else is going on and
so that'll help best detect it in cases
but then we've already failed you know
then we've had ten years worth of
transmission or more potentially before
we get the first human cases like we did
with Mad Cow and so our message has been
right now hunting is really important it
is a very important part of our society
frankly it's the way we managed your
herds thank God it's a huge economic
boon for running the kinds of DNR's as
such we have we balance the back as you
know from sportsman on these licenses
and so we don't want to stop hunting but
we've got to make sure that we and make
sure that people aren't getting infected
and one of the things that our group at
the university Minnesota is working on
is tests now they're almost like point
of detection tests so if you shoot an
animal could you know very quickly that
it's positive or not and then you'd know
not to process that animal yeah and
that's we need to get at well not only
that the the prions what's terrifying is
that how how invulnerable they are how
ridiculously vigorous they are when
Jacqueline you can boil them a thousand
degree temperature for hours and hours
and they're fine that's right when
they're when they're sanitizing medical
equipment that they've used on mad cow
patients or whether it's cows or humans
with these prions they've been able to
do it three times so try to sterilize
these things like the sterilization
process you wear the what is the
temperature that they do it for well
they do it both temperature and pressure
but it's in the hundreds and degrees and
it's under high pressure and I've
actually been involved with several
cases where these very equipment you're
talking about were accidentally used on
somebody hydro occupant disease and they
had to landfill it they couldn't they
couldn't even sterilize it if that's
what's insane like you can't kill these
things that's pretty hard that's why you
know we we want to make sure that if
you're eating deer cervus right now that
we have to make sure they're tested and
I think the other point you raised is a
good one we've been very concerned about
the movement of this disease by serving
farming yeah we've had far too many
examples and Doug has shared that with
you you know just the extent to which we
see if you know state by state by state
slowly getting you know picked off
because somebody moved a trophy deer
from state a to state B and
affected it got out or others got out of
the pens and then it affects locals ya
know has that made the jump to bison or
elk or any of those other animals yet
not yet it's several kinds of deer you
know but not not those mule deer so far
there has been some cases in the West
it's primarily whitetails right exactly
yeah and then there's been a deer in
Korea the type of drear there and and
one in the Scandinavian countries one
yeah I mean I mean different kinds of
deer types there yeah yeah so the one we
worry about right now is getting into
the caribou in northern Canada right now
the range of the deer that are infected
in the provinces of Canada is right
biting up next to caribou and of course
if you're not a hunter you would know
this but caribou obviously the herds are
remarkable unlike you know white tails
for that matter elk if you got it into
caribou the it would likely spread very
quickly and as you know the native
populations the caribou are key they're
key to their livelihood yeah so you
wouldn't want to see it get in the
caribou now I didn't even know that it
was in Canada what parts of Canada has
it been throughout a number of provinces
I think there's four provinces now it's
in its its in its skin spreading it's
the same phenomena that a combination of
deer movement with surveyed farming and
then once it's in an area it'll keep
migrating a bit and a bit as these
animals move somewhere but you know as
we know deer don't fly 4,000 miles every
season okay so it's not that kind of
movement if humans if we're gonna see a
big movement as humans are doing it as
our good friend Doug durin has been
doing all this work to try to alert
people about it and also they're putting
up these testing places where hunters
can bring it here and have the deer
tested how much of that is available to
people around the country though not
nearly enough and that's what we need to
work on is if you don't make it easy and
convenient as you know it's not going to
get done yeah and so we you know it's
hard enough to convince people if
there's really a problem because people
don't want to believe it even if they
know that there's you know CWD in deer
in the area and we have some like that
but I think the tide is changing more
and more people are sensitive to it they
have access to testing quickly but if
it's gonna take your month and have to
get the test back you know what it is
well well in some cases they get so busy
because you know unlike laboratory
testing for an entire year where I do
one twelfth and January one twelfth and
February of cetera cetera you know deer
season typically is very concentrated in
just a couple of weeks to a month in the
fall and so the problem is all the
animals come in at that time so your lab
capacity has to handle that huge surge
all at one time
and so somebody's it takes a while to
get it back so these hires just hope
they don't take a bite during that time
yeah and we hope that these prions don't
ultimately infect simple jump and but if
they do you know I worry what will
happen to deer hunting as we know it
because probably a lot of people will
you know not continue and we need that
desperately for herd management I mean
it's the way we do it well what they're
doing in Doug's area is they're they're
actively trying to eliminate a lot of
deer and try to lower drastically lower
the numbers particularly of bucks which
I guess they wander more yep they do
yeah yeah it's all really scary stuff
because if they do make the jump to
humans I mean it has made the jump to I
believe mice okay well what happened was
originally it didn't and so that was
some of the data that was used to
support it's not a problem right now
these what we call humanized mice or
mice that are basically much more like a
human we're now seeing that jump
occurring and these new strains see the
strains that again were around 20 years
ago or not the same ones today because
as these
prions continue to pass from animal to
animal to animal they go through these a
little minor mutations and they're
getting more more and more like what a
human transmissible prion might look
like so in these my studies now that are
really made to mimic a human we're
starting to see that jump yeah and folks
if you've never seen a deer with CWD you
should go and google it because it's
terrifying the idea that that could make
that jump to human beings and people
pouring saliva out of their mouths and
their whole body just wasted away to
skin and bones right that's what we're
looking at I mean that's why it's called
chronic wasting disease because the
animals literally waste away we actually
have a major resource and
on our website free of charge open and
it's all in chronic wasting disease so
people want to go there it's wlwt's it'd
wrap Cidra P dot you amend led you and
you can go there and all these pictures
all the time what is it again WWE app
CIDR AP CID wrap up just Center for
infectious ease research and policy said
wrap dot um n that edu dot um and II D
you and we have a lot of information
there it is that's it right there Center
yep and we've got a lot of information
on there also about coronaviruses we
have a whole Resource Center just for
the corona viruses to novel coronavirus
there you go hmm
so for the average person that is
sitting around reading these articles
that say don't worry our readings are
there's articles that say this is the
end of humanity what would what could
these people do like what what could
they do and what do they do if they get
infected
well first of all neither those kind of
articles are correct and we have to make
sure that we get that message out to
people that is Sarah we need Straight
Talk right now you know and and part of
it is it's so hard to you hear from
people who supposed experts what's this
going to happen or not happen you know
and and let me just give you an example
because we've heard a lot about well
it's going to go away with the the
chronic of the corona virus with the
seasons okay when it warms up it'll go
away well you know the other corona
viruses that we have that we've had to
worry about with SARS which appeared in
2003 in China and when that came out of
China in February 2003 it took us a
little while to figure out that these
people really aren't that infectious
tilde five or six of their illness and
then they really crash and burn and
mininum would die but what we did was
basically by knowing that identify these
cases in their context quickly and so if
they had symptoms brought him in put him
in these isolation rooms so they
wouldn't infect anybody else and it took
until june to bring out in her control
that had nothing to do with the seasons
MERS which is another corona virus
that's in the Middle East it's in the
Arabian Peninsula the natural reservoir
for that is camels in China by the way
stars it was palm civets and
a type of animal food rodent that we got
out of the markets there in the Arabian
Peninsula we're not going to euthanize a
1.7 camels you know to try to get rid of
MERS and there it's a hundred and ten
degrees out and this virus is
transmitted fine thank you
I mean it goes from animals to people it
goes in the hospitals there's no
evidence that seasonal there so that's a
good myth to expose right away this is
not something that's going to cure up
when it gets warm and it you know if it
does it won't be because there's a model
for it what will it be because how does
a how does something like SARS run
through a population and then stop being
around anymore well it wouldn't have but
had we had good public health had we had
you know the same kind of transmission
were seen as this corona virus where
your infectious before you ever get sick
where your highly infectious remember
with SARS now you didn't really get
infectious tell you're a six or you know
six days of illness and you knew that
you were in trouble and then you could
isolate you and we didn't understand
that at first and we transfer virus
transmitted so that's why SARS stop
murder stops because we don't get rid of
the camels so it keeps hitting humans
day after day but then when they go to
the hospital we no longer allow those
individuals to transmit to others in the
hospital because we do what we call good
infection control as soon as they get
there they're in special rooms with
special Mass and all this kind of thing
and so in that regard these chrome virus
can be stopped this one's not as I said
at the top of the program this is like
trying to stop the wind we influenza
transmission you never hear anybody
saying in a bad flu the seasonal flu
year you know we're going to stop this
one if you don't have vaccine that works
you don't it's just breathing that's all
it is so what's the best-case scenario
here well I think as I laid out to you
before you know this could be ten times
worse than a really bad seasonal flu
year and our grandchildren well it will
hit you know primarily the older
population and those underlying health
problems but as I mentioned also you
know we have a lot of people who have
other risk factors obesity high blood
pressure is another risk factor where
you can have a really bad outcome with
this and so we don't quite know what
it's going to do yet I think you know
we've been right on the mark predicting
where it's going to be today I think
from here on out I can tell you it's
going to stay around for months it's not
going to go away tomorrow we got to stop
thinking about if we just get through
tomorrow that's
so if we're gonna go to schools we're
gonna tell people not to go into public
Rona cancel big events how long are we
prepared to do that what are we gonna do
we have to ask ourselves that I think
the big thing is eventually enough
people get infected or it'll be like
putting reactors and the rods you know
rods in the reaction I should say and
then that stops it by itself but how so
because if you're if two of the three of
us in this room were immune right now to
it because we'd had it and recovered and
had protection because of natural
protection then I couldn't transmit to
anybody so that's what's going to happen
if you had enough people will get
infected ultimately then it'll slow down
and stop transmission that way but
that's the heck of a price to pay to get
there is it safe to say they were fairly
fortunate that this isn't something like
the Spanish flu or something that's
really ruthlessly deadly well that's
where I think we have to be really
careful just back up about 0.1% of
people who get seasonal flu diet and
grants it's mostly older or younger
people okay that's one out of a thousand
with this one right now in China we're
seeing between two and three percent of
the people die and some say well that's
way too high it's not going to be that
high it's going to be lower but again
and they say that because we didn't pick
up all the milder illnesses okay but on
the other hand we have a lot of
additional people in countries like ours
that have even more risk factors for
having bad outcomes in China and so
Spanish flu the one you mentioned 1918
that was about a three to three point
two percent case fatality rate now it
did preferentially impact 18 to 25 year
olds they they were the hardest yet
group why was that well you know it has
to do with your immune response again we
think that what happened is when this
virus got into you it created we call a
cytokine storm which is an antibody
response in your body that's out of
control and it basically you destroy
yourself and it sets this thing up to
trigger it off so the healthier people
had the more adverse reaction to exactly
or the other group that has had a real
challenge with that are pregnant women
and pregnant women have a very unique
issue one is course they have some
constriction of their lungs just by the
very physical mass but also their immune
system is really
at a heightened state at that point
there's a part of that immune system and
that woman says this is not all me get
rid of this it's like a rejection of a
graft and the other part saying this is
the most precious cargo ever carry you
know I got to make sure I don't lose it
and when that virus got in between those
two it started again that same kind of
cytokine storm now the thing that
concerns us about this what we saw in in
in 1918 I mentioned just three plus
percent this one could be as high as 2%
so it's somewhere between a really bad
flu here at 0.1% and it could be as high
up here you know getting closer to 1918
like and that's the numbers I just gave
you a few minutes ago from the American
Hospital Association of you know 480,000
deaths here in this country over the
next six to 12 months what can someone
do to shore up their immune system while
this is all going on well a couple
things first of all just being as
healthy as you can be you know wait wait
you know I'm I'm getting up there right
now or you know becomes more and more of
a challenge to stay you know in good
shape you know the more you can do to do
that something you know about you know
it's keeping and shaped is really
important a second thing is if you're on
medications like for blood high blood
pressure don't don't miss them take
those drugs because they're really
important even though they may not
appear simple you know you don't have
any symptoms of high blood pressure or
something like that and then I think
just you know getting sleep and eating a
healthy diet and that's about what we
can do today to help get you prepared
for this is there anything else someone
could do like maybe IV vitamin drips or
anything that's going to really boost
your system no you know when you look at
all the things that might be there and
I'm happy and willing to accept any and
all that might help but we don't really
have any data that those substantially
impact on your your immune system to
make it that much better
mmm it's not the case because not that
many people do it though no I actually
study has been studied and it's been
studied I mean a good example is you
know and I and I was one of those people
who thought boy this is a great thing
probiotics you know things turns out
that we've studied this with
the antibiotic resistance and does it
help your gut etcetera and it turns out
that the probiotic users were no
different than the non probiotic users
in terms of recovery from antibiotics no
and the issue of if you're gonna kind of
compete out the bad bug so by getting a
good healthy gut flora there you would
actually reduce the chance to picking up
a bad bug and it turned out there was no
difference the people how would they do
a study like that the only way I think
they would do a study like that
accurately is it in fact someone that is
the same person like you have the same
person with no probiotics yep and then
have them with probiotics what in in the
studies that have been done are very
close to that but what they did is they
use two different groups of people those
people used probiotics this group did
not right and then they looked at all
the illnesses and they got stool samples
and everybody and they got a sample this
is a group I don't have the numbers in
front of you they're pretty sizable
because I was disappointed I mean I was
thinking saw myself yeah yeah so I mean
I think though but I think the key
message here is is that you know we're
gonna get through this but right now we
do have some real challenges before us
what we can't tell people as it's all
safe you know I I every time I hear
people say the risk is law right now it
reminds me of what would happen if the
there was this huge low pressure system
you know five days off the coast at the
Gulf and there was ninety degree water
between that system and the beach and
there was no wind shear the northern
hemisphere wasn't likely gonna knock it
off but we tell the people standing at
the beach that day we have low risk of
anything well you know five days from
now it's coming right and so what we
need to do has helped us American
population or the world for that matter
understand we're gonna be in some hurt
for the next few months and we have got
to get better prepared how we gonna how
are we gonna work where we gonna work we
can't stop working we need when you ease
on lights on we need health I need food
so the a bunch of things people should
do that's gonna boost their immune
system that we know of right like get
sleep
drastically lower your alcohol intake
drink a lot of water uh-huh take
vitamins those kind of things things
that are gonna keep your body healthy
yep that's you nailed so it's not since
sauna will help you a little bit because
it does what relaxes you relaxes you it
also boosts up your heat shock protein
now if you're in Minnesota we'd say
there's a two-part requirement that you
got to go from the sonnet to the ice
water there's a sign yeah he had to do a
boat yeah people love that right we do
it all the time well the Russians
invented that yeah yeah yeah does that
have you ever done that I have my son
has a daughter have a beautiful Lake
place open northern Wisconsin they got a
son and like literally 12 feet from the
lake and there's a spring right there so
in the wintertime the lake actually
stays open so we go right from the Sun
and the hot tub right to the water and
back oh wow even when it's frozen
oh yeah it's well because it's not
frozen right through the spring yes so
you literally can go right into it so
and then you run right back into the hot
tub that's when you sleep well when
you've done a couple of those rounds you
sleep really well yeah yeah I would
imagine your body's freaking out yeah I
love the sauna but I haven't had any
opportunity to jump into a lake right
afterwards okay well we'll have to know
it just not anyway yet have a nice
covered yes really yeah that's the real
feeling yeah well what else can people
do in terms of all this hand sanitizer
jazz and masks is that all yeah
the hand sanitizers actually are a great
thing for stopping a lot of infectious
diseases they actually are really good
they're good for your hands you know in
terms of the skin they kill the bad bugs
but the whole issue of using your hands
touching your face at people all
concentrate on yes the data is actually
very weak that this what kind of virus
is gonna be transmitted that way so I
wouldn't tell you to stop using hand
sanitizers but don't think it's gonna
have a big impact on this book do you
see that viral video that's going around
that woman who was giving the address at
the behest of the White House and she
see that she tells people not to touch
their face and then immediately licks
her finger and I did saw page yeah I saw
that I saw that well why is she telling
people not to touch their face because
you know well the the thought was is
that there are receptors around your eye
right here that actually for this virus
could get in and then get into your body
and you know the data we have on this is
so sparse to say that that's the case I
think the primary thing about
hand-washing is legitimate but one of
the things we want people want to do
something they want to be able to fact
they're doing so
and so we tell them wash your hands
often in to present this to prevent this
disease and I feel like we're not being
really honest with the people that the
data and and we've looked at this very
carefully really is about just breathing
air and that's a hard thing to stop so
keep doing the hand-washing but don't
think that that's going to stop this
disease which you asked about the man to
stop other stuff yes yeah asks there's
two kinds right basically the surgical
mask which just fits over and the reason
it's called a surgical mask is because
it's loose-fitting just fits you know
kind of ties behind you because weren't
worn by surgeons so that they don't
cough or drip into your wound and it was
never made to protect you from bugs
coming in so those little spaces on the
sides that's not a problem if I'm
breathing into the cloth right in front
of my nose but in terms of the air
coming in on the side they're not
they're not effective at all so people
wear them they look like they're doing
something they're not now if you are
sick they may help a little bit from you
transmitting because if you cough then
you coffee right into that cloth and
it'll some little in bed in there or not
get out around the other one though is
called an in 95 respirator but for all
intents person looks like a mask it's
just tight face fitting it has the seal
but you know the nose etc that's an
apocalypse mask it could be I don't know
what those are but that could yes I'm
just saying that that's how I look at it
okay okay well they're actually we use
them all the time in health care all the
time and they use them in action about
90% of them are used in industry so
they're grinding things or asbestos etc
you know they don't breathe in all these
parts so if we have one of those that'll
do something they're very effective
they're very effective the problem is we
have a big shortage you know right now
we have hospitals that are down to just
a couple days worth of these masks those
respirators and it's because we don't
stockpile anything in this country you
know we don't have hospitals don't have
the money to do that
those Preppers right now are so excited
yeah all the Preppers across the guy I
knew it I knew the day would come
yeah well they are they are Ann teaches
and well you know but well this is
really important because how health care
workers go is how the country I think
we'll see we're going you know they've
been over 4,000 health care workers in
China who are infected many of them on
their job and a number of them died and
if in this country
we have a real challenge delivering
health care because we're overwhelmed
and then we have health care workers
picking up the infection like we talked
about the group in Milan and we don't
have the protection for them I really
believe that's when the public will say
oh wait a minute what's going on here
and and that's where I think the
challenge so we really have to protect
our healthcare workers they are the
frontline people and and the biggest
problem we have is a lot of these cases
need intensive care medicine which we
only have a limited number of beds for
but this is really sophisticated
medicine so when one of those people get
infected a doctor and nurse work in
intensive care it's not like you just
took out another soldier you took out a
special forces person you just can't
bring somebody in from family practice
wherever and put them in there and so
we've got to protect these workers and
I'm really concerned that that's one of
the areas we've not done
nobody stockpiles we have no you know
capacity to make lots of them all of a
sudden you know the prior to this event
the hospital purchasing agent would go
online click a button send me 5,000 of
these no be there the next morning has
anyone contacted you before this or
since in particular and asked for your
advice as to how they can better prepare
like columns of like the president oh
the president hasn't but I know a number
of the people were working in the White
House and they were contacted you oh
yeah well you know I've served roles in
the last five presidential
administrations I worked for two
Republican governors two Democratic
Governors as you appreciate one
dependent rasler I worked for two when
he was governor Jesse oh and and that's
right yeah and so you know I I've never
had a partisan you know I'm just a
private in the public health all right
and so I actually served as a science
envoy for this administration in the
State Department last year you know I'm
still in my full-time job at the
University and so I've never been I mean
I'm there to give the best advice I can
and so I've talked to a lot of these
people there at the CDC at Health Human
Services etc so yeah we've given a lot
of advice and do you think there's
anything that you could do now that
could help them make sure that we don't
have these shortages
of masks and shortages of medicine and
IV bags and something that could be done
- I mean you obviously you've laid out
all these problems yeah when you laid it
out in your book here the people could
buy right now go pick it up on Amazon
right video version of it as well there
is all right do you read it I'd the book
yes no you know you know I have think I
don't know I don't read my cell you know
there's actually a really good voice
it's not mine well it should be you man
drives me crazy someone else does it
yeah no you know this is the challenge
we have is today in this environment
everything's just in time delivery I
mean look at when you mean you go online
and you whatever place your everything
from Amazon wherever you back to throw
the next day yeah people forget that we
don't have that capacity today to
suddenly make lots of things so right
now all the mass manufacturers in North
America are working 110% time but if
they were trying to fill all the orders
they've gotten just in the last few
weeks would take him years and years
with the capacity they have and you
can't build build these new machines to
make masks overnight so this is
something that should be set in advance
of anything like this any pandemic
happening like long in advance we should
be prepared you know think about the
issue as defense you know we prepare all
the time well in advance we don't build
an aircraft carrier at the moment we
think we're gonna go to the battle we
look at what all do we need we don't do
that in public health we've tried and so
you know what stockpiling 500 million of
these in 95 s would have been the
difference between night and day and
when you look at the price of one of
those versus one airplane not even close
if you look at the things like that it's
like these medications I don't think
about our own Defense Department
employees are at risk of running out of
these critical drugs because they get
them from China I mean what a
vulnerability yeah so what we need to do
is take a step back after when we can
start now but we're not going to fix it
now is to say what are the key things
that we should do vaccines you know if
we had been serious about this we might
very well have had a corona virus
vaccine that whether worked specifically
for this strain whether it worked for
SARS or MERS but right after SARS
happened in 2003 everybody was hot at
Anu
scene and then when it went away the
interest waned is it something like the
flu where you know sometimes when they
come up with a few a flu vaccine it
doesn't necessarily address the current
strain yeah it could be and that's where
a corona virus family vaccine may not
match up right here now but it could and
and the flu one you've really hit an
important point there's one where you
know we do have an imperfect vaccine but
it still does a lot of good you know
fifty percent of the people are
protected that's heck a lot better than
zero yeah if we had a vaccine right now
that fifty percent of the people could
be protected against this virus man
think of all the lives we'd save so the
bottom line message is we can't wait and
tell the crisis to fix these things you
know what we spend about point zero zero
zero one percent of public health
compared to our Defense Department and
yet look how vulnerable the it's the
bugs it's not a war yeah it's not a
missile is bringing down the world
economy right now and it's a darn virus
yeah and so this is where I think that's
what I tried to say in my book was all
about that I went into what we needed to
do in fact I hate it when people come up
and say we're screwed you know my whole
bottom line is what are you gonna do
about it then and that's what I laid out
a whole plan in here like these vaccines
like the stockpiles of mass you know we
should have a plan in place already what
are we gonna do with our schools when
they close are we gonna really close
schools let's not try to make this on
the fly you know I just mentioned if we
close schools we're gonna really hurt
some people
and people may die in health care
facilities hospitals because we don't
have enough nurses or health care
workers why have to make that decision
all of a sudden we could have planned
for that a long time ago
and so I think hopefully this is a
wake-up call cos you know nobody I think
really believed this I got a tape you
know the market today as you know
on this particular day crashed badly and
you know I think that up until 10 days
ago the market didn't even think this
was a possibility they just if you look
at it was flying high on Friday I did a
briefing for over 400 major financial
investors around the world and you know
I you know how I'm talking to you right
now you know I'm not trying to be scary
I'm just trying to tell the facts and
make sure people understand it the
questions I got from these people all
remind me of a six-year-old who was
afraid to have to go throughout a dark
or dark hallway you know and and and I
thought I actually said to friends and
colleagues Friday night I said you know
what Monday's markets not gonna look
good because I could sear the fear in
these people okay well we shouldn't be
there we should be what are we going to
do we have a problem you know it's like
a forest fire whatever we got a problem
what are gonna do about it financially
how we gonna get through this you know
where are we gonna go with it no plans
again it's caught everybody by surprise
I mean you are the one of the few people
that wanted to deal with this issue you
know we set this up several weeks ago
yeah you guys saw it coming you know and
and I think that's where the country
hasn't seen it now they're getting it
well I'm paranoid well I seek the advice
of experts whenever possible and what
what I was seeing was that there was a
lot of weird misinformation and
conflicting information a lot of people
saying don't worry and a lot of people
that were terrified I'm like okay I got
to talk to an expert and luck yeah you
were willing to sit down with us and
help us out well you know and the other
thing I think that you know I maybe it's
a function of age but you know straight
talk is so important today you know you
know I'm so tired of having people say
to me oh if you tell them the stuff
they're gonna panic and I say well
what's panic have you seen anybody
rioting in the streets yet have you seen
cars turned over smash have you seen
people hurting themselves over this
issue they're concerned you know they
want legitimate information and so what
you need to do is just tell them the
truth and we have many experiences like
that a few years ago when I was at the
State Health Department Minnesota we had
a big outbreak of meningitis a type of
brain infection bacterial brain
infection a number of high school
students were very sick all of a sudden
in one day they were in a hospital in
this community of 20-some thousand
people were on edge and so we had a big
town meeting several thousand people
showed up and I addressed them and gave
me everything I knew about meningitis
what we're gonna do about it etc and
then towards the end of the talk I said
and I just need to let you know about
one on every seven cases of this dies
and people looking said why did you tell
of that and I said because they needed
to know it two days later one of them
died and you know what everybody in town
was terribly sad very emotional but they
we knew it we knew it you told it we
knew it right and then they got on with
dealing with it we vaccinated the whole
town 20,000 people who vaccinated one
weekend for this bacterial meningitis
but it was because they had faith in us
because we told them the truth and we
said what we know and what we didn't
know and so that's what we need to do
here we need to just have Straight Talk
don't tell him it's low risk that's like
the hurricane okay you know I would be
really bad at you if I thought you were
a hurricane forecaster and you knew this
was coming but you kept telling me oh
it's low-risk don't worry about it right
yeah once it hit yeah so that's what we
need to do today is just say this is
gonna be challenging and we're gonna get
through it though we are going to get
through it I hope this wakes people up
to the value of vaccines - there's so
many wackos out there to think that
vaccines are you know a scam or they're
dangerous or that's there's so many
people out there that won't vaccinate
their children I know and that's one you
know what are your best shows beater
hotels he's a dear friend of mine he's a
I do too he's a dear friend of mine as
you and you know he is one of the
champions out there on this very issue I
couldn't agree with you more I think
that's really an important point that
you know we got to get this idea these
vaccines can be life-saving if we had
one right now think how different the
situation being we're in right now it
would be radically different but you see
the measles making it come back and
directly attributed to a lack of
vaccines you know what and it's not only
the vaccines themselves but it's the
prioritization of vaccines I mean well
you know one of the real tragic stories
right now in Africa is we are just
finally bringing to a close this
outbreak of Ebola in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo far northeast part
of the Congo you know 20-some thousand
people have died from this okay
bad been going on for almost two years
and everybody talks about that and I
understand why bola is a challenge but
you know that during that same time
period over 7,000 kids in that same area
have died from measles because everybody
was preoccupied trying to deal with
Ebola and in that those deaths were
totally preventable totally preventable
so yeah I mean I I think that's you know
I I have to say and you know this I'm
already on this show so I'm not trying
to thank you for what you do say about
vaccines because people listen to you
and we
need every positive voice because we
have so many crazy voices out there
right now Center so paranoid and
delusional and they want it all to be a
conspiracy there's been an amazing
medical innovation in in human culture
and that's vaccines
it's amazing what it's done and have
there been adverse perfect effects on
people of course everything everything
that people do there's some people are
gonna react in a bad way
it doesn't mean it's not a positive
thing and there's a reason why the cases
of polio are so tiny there's a reason
why smallpox went away it's because of
vaccines absolutely and you know what
that's one of the challenges you know
today between the the anti science
misinformation that's out there but then
when they don't see it yes and the
reason they don't see it is because we
did vaccinate until we get enough people
not vaccinated and then look what
happened there's a famous photo of two
twins from the early 20th century one of
them has smallpox and one of them was
vaccinated have you seen that I have I
have I have it's alive to my photo very
Kelly Jamie you'll find it because it's
people need to see it that that that is
the dirty up there is right there that's
it right there that's the one
one kid whose body is just devastated by
what looks like he's like pebbles glued
to his skin all over his body's face his
hands and then the his brother right
next to them with nothing and you know
what's really important to note here is
is that in that body all those things
are very painful but what's going on
inside the body is equally bad yeah and
so you're exactly right I couldn't agree
with you more
that you know this is this is really an
important point diseases are terrifying
they're really terrifying yeah and when
something like this can be prevented and
the reason why people don't do it is
because they're paranoid of vaccines and
they get that information from some
wacko website or some person who really
has no business talking about it you
know whether it's the people out there
that think it causes diseases or that
it's a government plot or that it's a
medical scam is just trying to raise
raised money it's just all that all of
its very very disturbing but it's a part
of people you know the human beings for
whatever reason
there's a percentage of us that lean
towards conspiratorial thinking and they
lean towards thinking that there's some
sort of a plot against them or the
governments against them and it's just
you gotta listen to the medical experts
you know and I hope that if there's any
good to come out of this terrible
coronavirus situation is there's a
wake-up call
if we'd had a vaccine for this or one
that even worked partially yeah think
how different we'd be and you know what
we got new other ones coming like those
we have to use our creative imagination
you know as I said in the book I the
chapter on coronavirus is the title is
SARS and MERS a harbinger of things to
come
yeah I mean we don't we can use our
creative imagination to say we should be
funding these things almost like we pay
for our fire department imagine if we
had to go out and buy a fire truck and
when the 9-1-1 call came in yes we need
to do it now it's kind of disturbing
that's chapter 13 though I know it was
well actually
would you do me a favor you're gonna
really a bit like this okay open up up
to chapter 13 okay and when you look at
it's towards the end there when you read
the quote that goes with it
okay okay so every every chapter started
not with just a title but of a quote and
and I think you'll find this one quite
interesting bioterror opening Pandora's
box that's not it that's not the chapter
that's not it yes chapter 13 you're
closed okay we stars and MERS a
harbinger of things to come let's look
at the quote underneath these make me
look smarter Rudyard Kipling am the dawn
comes up like thunder water china crost
the bay china china what you said you
did you put that in there because it
really thought that a lot of this stuff
was going to come out of China was that
exactly no it says this is exactly we're
talking about why do you why China
because they have this incredibly large
population two million they've got this
food supply that is largely wildlife
that comes into these markets whether
there's this incredible contact between
people and these animals and the crowded
nature of that society I mean I think
one of the things that surprises people
to go to China
15 million population cities are common
over there I mean we think of the United
States we think of LA in New York and
that's big okay over there I mean in
Wuhan a city of 15 million the entire
metropolitan area is 60 million and so
you have people crowded so closely
together that if you add in the bugs
coming from these animals and then the
potential for this kind of contact where
it spreads quickly China has been a you
know a bacterial and viral soup vessel
for a long time that's again why we have
to protect ourselves here because a bug
anywhere in the world today can be a bug
everywhere tomorrow and particularly
when you're dealing with a massive
number like these kind of cities so
these wet they call them wet markets
markets yep so that's what it is a lot
of it is wildlife oh it's incredible you
know you know I've hunted my life you
know I've always loved to fly fish I
love the outdoors okay I could never
have imagined the animals you know I've
spent time in these markets I remember
one day spending a day in the Bangkok
hanging at island market and it was
about a mile by mile half wild big I
mean and these tight aisles
every animal imaginal the humans and I
swear to god there were some out of the
movies I think that we're in there and
they're all just right on top of each
other and I actually have a picture that
I show in some of my lectures there is a
situation where there's all these
chickens in a cage
I know 15 or 20 of them okay a big wire
cage and it sat on top of a wider cage
full of ferrets and ferrets are actually
an animal model from flu standpoint that
they do really well getting infected
with flu viruses if you wanted to create
the perfect experiment that no no
University you know research group would
let you do is you'd put Birds and
ferrets like that together and that's
just common that's just common that's
common and so birds and ferrets together
the
something that's infecting the birds
could jump to the ferret surprise air
could breathe it out and we could get
infected Christ and so these markets and
in the I don't know what's going to
happen here but for the first time we
really saw the Chinese after this
outbreak in Wuhan really start to put
down some markers on what they're gonna
do to supervise these markets I mean
they self to eat but I think this is a
dangerous practice where we see it but
you know what happens and look at Africa
with Ebola right you know bush meat is
still very important and there's so much
of the world that that's their primary
food supply and when they say bush meat
it's basically everything everything
from bats we think that was the primary
source of this outbreak in West Africa
was a human bat that was consumed to eat
him all the time really yeah yeah so you
know and some of them are pretty big
bats you know they're they're literally
3 feet wing spans or they're big and so
you know that's one of the challenges we
have with with China we know that this
is going to happen it's going to occur
we think of the flu virus is the same
way and that's why we knew doing better
flu vaccines
you know this could just as easily be
flu pandemic the same thing like 1918
so these wet markets they just have all
these animals hanging out and some of
them are still alive many of them are
alive and you know they'll actually
prepare them for you right there
they basically kill them and got them
and so forth you got some pictures of
bizarre Wuhan Westman there you go
Market menu shows over a hundred wild
animals sold as food linked with virus
unclear exactly what it looks like it's
pretty amazing yeah let's see some
images whoa whoa look at that rip look
at that list I know he talks yeah people
are eating pika oh yeah absolutely
dear crocodiles turkey Swan Seton swans
how dare you kangaroo squirrel snails
foxes foxes and civet cats were the
cause of the SARS up ostriches I've had
that pretty delicious yep I'm a
hypocrite look at me just centipedes
geese hedgehogs goats Jesus so yeah it's
a pheasant right that's normal so do we
have a video of the market I want to see
what whoa
that freaky looking salamander size of
that sucker big it that's a huge
salamander I wouldn't like for you first
the pictures I was fine and dark yeah
come on what do you got cages of turtles
and cages of bunnies oh yeah see it
wow this wet market is very very so and
these are enormous markets well they're
huge they're in the number of people in
them is incredible I mean they're
getting the Animus from they're getting
them from the water'll area from rural
areas yeah yeah are they growing these
things and farming them or are they some
cases bone some cases both like a lot of
the seafood today is actually being
farmed so this is really like a giant
petri dish yeah yeah I mean it's almost
you're looking that fish looks not not
that fresh whoa what's all that stuff
rabbits and rabbits yeah Jesus but
you're getting them on the ground why
you know if we can't stop that we surely
can try but if we can't so that we need
to stop the infectious diseases coming
from those animals to us look at them
all wearing masks that's hilarious
that was I think with the outbreak was
that that might have been those gigantic
things a mollusk what is that what are
those things can't tell those look like
giant mollusks yeah they are right no
because yeah I'm ones behind I think
you're right like huge muscles Wow look
at those suckers behind them Wow yeah
there's a lot of people in China they
got to eat that's where it gets weird
right this it's like how do you tell
them that they've been doing they've
been doing this for who knows how long
how do you tell them to stop doing it or
is is that impossible and is it more
possible to just accelerate our vaccine
program and try to preemptively create
something to to address coronaviruses to
address various various differently what
other what other viruses are we
concerned about other than coronavirus I
think I think it's both I think the next
most would not even next it's don't it's
a cold virus you might call influenza I
mean you know there have been 10
influenza pandemics in the last 250
years
and each one of them was a little
different but some have been horribly
bad you know back in the 1500s even
there was a major pandemic that occurred
where Spanish cities were described as
normally almost totally depopulated and
so these viruses pop out and that's why
we need new and better flu vaccines and
we're all actually working on one now
but it's still a ways off but having
those would really prevent the big
calamities meaning you know some of the
things are gonna happen they're not good
but they're not going to bring down
supply chains and threaten governments
and so forth and so I think the priority
vaccines we need to get are for those
diseases that we know could is the flu
injection the most effective way or is a
mist as effective like the I know that
did do the mist up the nose yeah turns
out that what research we have and our
group was involved with some of it the
flu mist and the nose works really well
on children mostly because they haven't
been infected yet themselves they don't
have any protection and so that virus
really multiplies in the nose remember
this virus is adapted not to multiply in
your lungs because the nose is colder
than the lung and so it'll grow here it
won't if you swallow it it won't grow in
your lungs if you've already been
infected ones then you actually have
some interference in your nose there's a
little bit of protection there so it
works well in kids who haven't been
infected before adults not so well for
us the injection works best and you know
I'm happy to report that although I'm
not happy to report being an old man now
I can even get the high-dose vaccine
over age 60 so so they are actually you
know the best we have the high-dose
vaccine is better yeah it's better than
the regular vaccine in turn you hit a
certain age yeah but when you get a
little older you need the higher dose
because your immune system starting to
wane
you know you can actually have an less
but what we need and aware that there
was yeah there's a high dose there's a
high dose yeah there's a higher dose
vaccine oh so where do you get it like
where if a person's listening this and
they like any doctor any doctor's office
and they will usually say that too if
you're old for you know 60 you can get
this vaccine so they'll actually do that
for you so yeah so run out get a get a
vaccine because - now is pretty much
over the flu season is waning I mean if
you hadn't gotten it you should have had
it a couple of months ago okay this
one's waning now we've had a bad flu
season really bad
but for the last couple weeks the
numbers are coming away down so what
what can person do other than the
vaccine to prevent getting the flu
that's primarily yet again it's a issue
of who you're around you know and you
know your body's overall health yep and
just keep healthy as you can and then I
think the other key piece though is if
you do get the flu and you have really
bad muscle aches one of the things about
in real influenza is not just sniffles
you feel like you got hit by a Mack
truck
if after several days you still are
really feeling bad really bad and you
haven't seen a physician by then you
should because that's when you get the
complications occurring the bacterial
pneumonias that occur subsequent and if
you get those treated earlier than later
you can actually do a lot to keep
somebody from dying so you know if you
don't feel a lot better in two days I
mean if you if you catch it really early
you can get a medication for flu there's
actually a medication that will reduce
your illness a bit but if you're if
you're sick for more than a couple days
not better
you absolutely should see a doctor so
you don't have these other complications
and what kind of doctor do once you any
family any family practitioner would
know what to look for and whether or not
your lungs are starting to fill up
you know if they'll they'll listen to
your lungs to make sure you're not going
developing pneumonia and what would they
do for you they would likely give you an
antibiotic based on what you had because
you are then this the problem with flu
is it's not just the flu virus but then
you get secondary bacterial pneumonia
from the damage in the lungs and so they
can prevent that a lot of older people
in particular will die from actually
what we call secondary pneumonia to
having had influenza they wouldn't
gotten the pneumonia if they had not had
flu but then they do now we were talking
earlier about probiotics do do is there
a benefit of probiotics once you've
taken antibiotics to Riefler --is-- your
gut flora you know that's where the
studies really at this point have
demonstrated that it's very temporary in
other words if you're taking probiotics
you can get a boost initially but it
doesn't sustain yourself over time and
then the natural flora comes back I mean
the gut microbes will come back as as
they've been reduced but what I'm saying
is is it beneficial to people if they do
take a probiotic after antibiotics
antibiotics do have a devastating effect
on your floor yeah
kills the bad stuff but it also kills a
lot of the good stuff right yeah so is
it beneficial for people once they have
taken an antibiotic to take probiotics
to sort of reflect an pereira yeah and
that's what i'm saying is that it
doesn't the data don't support that it
stays in other words you get a
short-term boost material but they don't
stay around what if you just keep taking
it even then they they just don't stay
around your normal gut flora will come
back and take over so the probiotics and
of themselves are not giving you that
long-term boost so you don't think
there's any benefit to having even even
a short-term boost well you know it's
again I surely I'm not gonna profess to
be the expert on probiotics right tell
you that the data we have doesn't show
that they have a big boost and and that
they actually help you long term or
short term meaning that it makes any
difference now there's one exception to
that where I would say and this is a
very different thing than probiotics but
we actually have a disease called
Clostridium difficile which is a bad
bacteria that happens when you've taken
away too many antibiotics and and it's
colonizes your gut because you don't
have competing organisms there and then
you can die from this there are
treatments for that called actually
fecal transplants yeah I've heard of
that and that's where actually there you
take it little capsules but it's
actually drinking poop when purified
purified bugs from the poop you're right
but you take that and that's that's that
kind of is what you're talking about
that does have a real benefit and there
is clear evidence that if you take those
those fecal transplants as opposed to
just probiotics or such that that can
have a major positive impact on your
recovery from things like claustrum
difficile infection and so more and more
institutions now actually are doing
fecal transplants which you'd never
thought that that would be one thing you
do one day but after those have had this
problem they're there life-saving there
maybe we should change the name that
would although on the other hand you
don't forget it if yeah yeah you don't
forget if it's a fecal transplant but
that's what's gonna be yeah
nerve-wracking to people yeah yeah you
know once you're that sick boy it feels
good to take
it does you know have you done it I've
never done it I've never had a problem
where I've had to but but for the I've
know people who have been desperately
sick who have taken them and have really
done much better much much better I want
to ask you about Lyme disease sure Lyme
disease is a scary one
right and I mean so many of my friends
in the East Coast have it it's really
terrifying that that that part of the
country in particular seems to be like
really badly infected with these these
ticks that carry this disease what can
people do to prevent that and what can
we there's no vaccine for Lyme disease
and I know there was at one point but
people were having an issue with I mean
a good friend of mine her dad actually
got Lyme disease from the vaccine before
they discontinued it what can someone do
to sort of protect themselves
yeah well Lyme disease in of itself is a
fascinating story I've actually been
involved with it since its early
discovery in the 1980s and Minnesota
Wisconsin was a big focus the Upper
Midwest and this is a story that I think
you'll find interesting is is that even
though it was discovered primarily in
the eastern part of the United States
named after a Lyme Connecticut it's a
disease that actually probably
originated in the Upper Midwest and I
tell you that because it turns out that
there is a focus in northern Wisconsin
in and east central Minnesota where
there's Lyme disease there's another
disease called anaplasmosis there's
another disease but Visia etc that all
seem to have a similar kind of tick
human deer kind of component and back in
the ccc days of the 1930s the
white-tailed deer population had been
virtually totally depopulated from the
northeast and so they actually trapped
deer in northern Wisconsin and took them
out and de+ in the New York and
Connecticut and so forth and most of
those deer are actually deer that you
know today their great great great great
great grandfather came from Wisconsin
Wow and guess what when you move deer
you move ticks in fact I was involved
with the study that the Wisconsin
Division of Health did and a colleague
of mine the late Jeff Davis
we're up in northern Wisconsin as deer
would come into the check station and
they would actually measure the number
of ticks that were attached to the nape
of the neck okay and they had a lot of
thing drawn and they asked hunters who
were driving back to Madison and
Milwaukee if they would be willing to
check in at a station down there for
just a second and then they were gonna
count the ticks again and it turned out
that as the vehicles come rolling down
from highway 51 from northern Wisconsin
get on the interstate 90 94 and go to
Milwaukee or Madison the ticks just kept
falling off by the time they get to
Madison or Milwaukee the ticks are
almost all gone
well guess lo and behold where all the
Lyme disease so forth started to show up
right along the interstate corner Wow
because the ticks were coming off and
then they were getting into the local
deer in that population and so it's
exactly you said the ticks are moving
they're moving okay they've moved and
they're now infected so I think that
that this Lyme disease issue is a key
one Lyme disease is really an important
disease it's real no question about it
the challenge we have is is that there's
a lot of people that assume that they
have chronic Lyme infection and you know
the data on that is just really really
not there to support that these people
are chronically infected but they do
have an immune response likely that
occurs where it sets up this trigger and
so they're sick they actually have
something but it's not treating it again
for the bacterial infection it's the
fact that this body your bone body's
immune systems we've talked about
several times today but starts attacking
you site I think it's a similar picture
we see with chronic fatigue syndrome
same kind of thing these people really
are sick they really do have problems
but it's not something you can treat so
when people I I have a challenge because
when people take IV antibiotics at
extended periods of time for Lyme
disease you know the data there's four
different studies not have been done
where people have had what we call a
double-blind of control
well SIBO controlled trial where half
got the drug half got a IV but no drug
and it turned out all four of these
studies and Lyme disease the people who
got the gist the placebo did just the
same as the people
got the drug and I worry that we're
using antibiotics a lot there and this
is where I just mentioned earlier about
claustrum difficile we actually had a
patient Minnesota that died from the IV
treatment for what was chronic Lyme
disease and wouldn't have been helpful
and so we need a lot more research in
this area to figure out what are these
people getting what is it that we can
shut off so that they don't have this
chronic Lyme disease picture knowing
that it's not actually just you had a
treat of more treatments that can help
them with the antibiotics anymore and so
I think that that's an area that we just
need a lot more work in and the numbers
are growing as you know yeah so we don't
we don't know what's happening well
there's a we have enough data to say
your immune system is really cranked up
our immune system is you know just like
something yeah it's like rheumatoid
arthritis a lot of things well you know
we you know thank God for our immune
system is what fights off all the bad
things we have but sometimes that immune
system gets turned on too much yeah and
then it takes on us okay and and it goes
back to the corona virus that's why a
lot of these people are dying right now
is this over vigorous immune response
and Lyme disease is kind of that in Fame
and sighting event where we have
evidence now that you could be infected
with the bacteria but if we treat you
it's not like it's like every other
bacteria you can really get rid of it
but you still have this chronic illness
that's occurring and what I think is
hard is is that we see people who have
this who are desperate to have somebody
understand what they have and they end
up going to people who take a real
advantage of clinicians who charge them
an arm and a leg for things that are not
going to help them and what we need is a
lot more research on what is actually
going on and what kind of drugs can we
use to reverse this immune system
disorder I have a friend of mine who's a
UFC fighter Jim Miller and he's he's got
Lyme disease and it's pretty bad I mean
he takes a stack of pills I don't know
what he takes every day yeah what do you
think someone is taking and what what
benefit would they get from that I
couldn't tell with I mean I'm not you
know without knowing what's there but
again more often than not effuse been
adequately treated it's not that the
bacteria still growing in him
like it might be for a lot of it it's an
autoimmune it's autoimmune too which is
real I mean that's the other thing is I
think these people just want to be
legitimized and said you know I'm really
sick right and I'm not it's not
something I'm you know mentally ill
about whatever but then we've got to
figure out what it is that you have and
so we really don't know we don't know
yet we don't know wow but it's been
around for so long I know but this is
where we need a lot more research about
this of in terms of what is it that's
making these people like this and this
is really important and is there
anything they can do to eradicate the
text you know that this is another thing
you'll find interesting in Minnesota
prior to the arrival of the first
whiteman the Native Americans burned
much of our state all the time the
prairies from much of the territory
even in northern Wisconsin in northern
Minnesota we had the classic you know
pine forest firewood wipes room and with
that it would open up so much of the
forest that you'd have a very different
kind of mammals population diro cetera
cetera and with the suppression of fire
what's happened is we now have instead
of having these old-growth forests we
have all this younger you know non pine
or any kind of like the oak trees of the
Upper Midwest are all disappearing
because oak trees need sunlight and
fires what kept they were very resistant
to fire and so the old oak forests and
so forth would would survive because of
fire whereas today with no fire you know
the Elms and the maples and everything
else comes in and the buckthorn all that
kind of stuff and takes over so so
what's happening is in our state of
Minnesota is we have a really good
example of this as we're losing our
moose and the big primary reason is
brain worm it's rain more brain room
it's a type of parasite that's common
and whitetail deer but causes no
problems in moose it actually causes a
brain infection and it kills them and
guess why is happening because the deer
range has moved farther and farther
north in Minnesota try to keep this I'm
sorry that has moved farther in North
Miller in Minnesota because of lack of
fire because the forest is changing so
now where they're only used to be moose
we're seeing deer and moose and where
that intersection is
we're starting to see moose develop this
brain worm infection because it's from
the deer so the tick population has
changed too and it's largely due to the
fire lack of fire in many places in the
Northeast never used to be like it was
we had fire all the time that would
clear out these areas and it was just a
part of natural everything so so one of
the challenges we have with ticks is
they're here we're not gonna change how
we live suburbs and you know trees and
all that controlled burns eliminate a
lot of them they do because what they do
is they just eliminate the ticks but
what they do is they eliminate for
example the white field mice or all
these different species that are
important to the ticks and then they
bring in different species that will
will be there so I mean this is a big
debate in Minnesota right now I mean
we're losing all these moose to brain
worm ironically the moose or population
is expanding dramatically and I'll Royal
why because there's no deer out there
and so they're not getting brain worm
out there so people have said you know
the we're gonna lose our moose well so
it's the deer so
so fire actually has helped the most in
areas in northern Minnesota where
there's been a lot of fire the moose
population is growing because the deer
are not there because exactly those
mammals those rodents and so forth are
very different in burnt-out areas and
they are and find non burnt-out areas
well they do control burns in some
states I got a I had a friend who's
hunting in Washington State a couple of
years ago and he said it was really
weird because there's these massive
fires in the distance that were actually
being controlled they do it on purpose
yeah which is a lot better than having
the out of control fires where you have
so much fuel yeah and you know if you
haven't had a forest fire in eighty five
hundred years in an area the fuel and
there's huge yeah and so actually they
do that in northern Minnesota - they're
doing control burns and the prairies of
course we do control burns all the time
so but the problem with the East Coast
is you're dealing with a lot of these
sort of almost residential areas that
have all these ticks yeah you can't then
they're you can't there we have to find
ways that's that's where we really have
to have vaccines and treatments for
these diseases Rock get rid of the ticks
so what we have to do is figure out I
mean wouldn't we have a cocktail vaccine
for male Babesia for Lyme disease for
yeah you know that's what we need is
there any kind of an animal that eats
ticks
birds yeah birds will eat them but not
enough no no no no they're they're doing
very well thank you ticks do very well
and that's another issue you know for
some of the larger mammals as you know
tick predation can get so heavy
particularly in in in certain times of
the year that the it really literally
takes a lot of blood on these large
animals even though they're so big yeah
rabbit hold the other day online and I
saw this one deer that was covered in
these frisbee sighs yeah patches of
ticks that's exactly what all swollen
also and they're full of blood
oh and it happens day after day so that
it is a hit on them it's a real hit on
them to pull up a picture of that just
have freaked people out of watching
online just they need to see this yeah
yeah it's pretty amazing it's one of
those things that when you talk about
ticks and you talk about Lyme disease
most people their eyes glaze over they
don't even care it's not affecting me
until someone in your family has it yep
there's a guy that I know who was a
former UFC fighter Marcus Davis who he
put he had his wife got Lyme disease and
he spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars trying to trying to help burn
and do something about in treatments and
all these different things for it yeah
it's a it's a real challenge it's a
challenge and this is another area again
you know when you think of the amount of
money we lose in just lost time let
alone pain and suffering yeah what an
investment to make it is I mean this
this is the kind of thing this is where
infectious diseases really needed a
renaissance I mean well we do a lot here
we pulled up a chart of the United
States where they showed the areas that
are affected by these ticks and what
what percentage of ticks carry Lyme
disease they've tested and some places
in the Northeast this and the 60% Oh
exactly
yeah it is it's huge it's growing and
it's ground
I mean you've made me you and understand
how wildlife has changed I mean look at
to think that we have all these wild
coyote populations in New York City now
yes it mean it's amazing how the animals
the city in the country yeah you know
what the rats aren't doing the coyotes
are taken out and it's it's it's a
challenge I mean these are effect
infectious disease issues too they're
they're very real yeah they have coyotes
in Central Park they do yeah absolutely
then the Bronx they have them and it's
weird it's weird to see because this is
something
just didn't exist before look at this
that's very good that's okay yeah that's
okay that's not not that's not the best
I've seen but it's gross enough yeah it
is it gives you a good sense of it
though yeah dan Flores who has been a
guest on the podcast before has a great
book called coyote America that sort of
details how this came to be and how
these coyotes have look at that all over
that poor deer look at the eye on the
fawn yeah yeah they're disgusting yeah
but the Coyotes about how when they got
rid of the wolves and they tried to do
the same to the coyote they just
actually expanded their territory and
they're sneaky
very clever little animals adaption yeah
just like microbes adaption you know is
there anything else that we should cover
no I mean I think I thank you for
covering this issue an interesting
disease as we can use all the help we
can to get people to be aware of what's
out there and what's coming and just
keeping the message straight and we're
gonna get through this but at the same
time it's going to be a challenge you
know today you have an underlying health
problem and you're particularly over age
50 55 I'd say avoid big crowds if you
can and that's going to be really
important and know that we're gonna work
on the critical drug supply to make sure
that people aren't without drugs that
save their lives every day that's gonna
be a big challenge
one more question how long does it take
to develop a vaccine for this
coronavirus well you know when I'm asked
that question I don't mean to sound glib
again but I can make a vaccine for an
overnight the question is is it safe and
effective hmm and that's the challenge
we have right now questions about how do
you make community to a coronavirus and
what kind of vaccines you have to have
that brings in all the different parts
of the immune system so we don't know
that yet so some of this research is
going to have to be basic to that the
second thing we have to worry about of
safety there's a condition in humans
called antibody dependent enhancement
8ee and it turns out that if you have no
antibody or immune response you'll get
the disease if you have a lot you're
protected but if you have this
in-between level and then you get the
disease it actually enhances the disease
immune response is really destructive
and in fact there was just a couple
years ago a major recall of dengue
vaccine the type of vaccine we used for
mosquito infection in the Philippines
were kids who got the vaccine actually
made just a little bit of antibody and
when they got the real disease that made
him a lot sicker and so we found with
the 2003 SARS vaccine that there was an
80 e component to it when we made it in
animals and so we're gonna have to
really study this to be sure it's safe
and as you said earlier you know we can
surely make mistakes we don't you know
we needed to I mean we can not - and so
I think between getting the
effectiveness and the safety data
together were years out I mean maybe
years yeah this is not going to happen
soon yeah you know it's wishful thinking
you know every time I mean I go back to
SARS in 2003 and look at every event
Zika 2015 we said Oh we'll have a
vaccine for it in no time here we are
five years later and we've no vaccine
and so this is one of the challenges we
have we have to complete the job you
know it's like we start on something and
then we forget that it's important
because it kind of goes away for a while
but only to come back and so this is
part of that picture we talked about and
this is what Peter Hotez talks a lot
about you know we gotta finish the job
on these things you know I worry that
we'll get through this situation and
then people say oh we're done and then
we'll forget until the next one comes
along and so so this is where vaccine
research and development is really
important how do they test for safety so
once they come up with a potential
vaccine how do they make sure that it's
safe what you do it gradually first of
all you put it into animals to see and
you know enough about them how their
immune responses what do they do then
you put it into a few humans 30 humans
you know they volunteer willingly
knowing to see what kind of reactions
they have well I would just take really
bad people that are in jail and practice
on them well I I don't know if that's
doable here in this country without
their informed consent so I'll just
wrump can fix that anybody if we have a
shot at doing that with any president
it's try just start with rapists yeah so
anyway the bottom line though is is that
then they gradually work their way up to
larger studies where you know if
something happens one every thousand
people you have to study a lot of people
before you know the chance that you
might find that right
30 people so that's why it's gonna take
a while and you know they'll test it on
more and more people and they're going
as fast as they can
it's not like there's anybody dragging
their feet it's just that you know I
joke in lycée it's like if the Iowa
farmer wanted to harvest corn in half
the time it doesn't mean by planting
twice as many acres he can do that you
know planting in April you still can't
harvest October that's a good thing
that's what this is it's gonna take us
this long to get this vaccine well
Michael I appreciate you and I
appreciate your time and deadliest enemy
people go out and buy it and thank you
for informing yes and thanks for being
here it means a lot to us thank you very
much thanks thank you
oh I'd love to I'd love to get a fish
with you
[Music]